okay so that was in november 22nd 63.  today  are we safer today are presidents safer  today or is the likelihood of something  like that happening higher today than it  was  you know  53 years ago well i could say this  the job of the secret service today is  much more challenging  than it was challenging today much more  challenging than it was in 63 or  the 50s 60s or 70s even the 80s there  are so many new things going on in the  world  technology is a wonderful thing but it  can work  against you and it can work for you and  you always  are challenged by that new technology i  am so  respectful of the agents that are  working today because they really have  their hands full thank god we don't use  open cars anymore  but even so uh i've always said that you  never know what's around the corner you  have no idea until you get there